this is probably a totally whack move
but I'm very interested in what the
internet thinks your net worth is oh can
we look that up to have you ever looked
at your own celebrity net worth I have
but I don't remember it oh yeah yeah
because it was yeah I don't remember let
me tell you why I find this particularly
fascinating because the business model
of ICP is like it
it's
it's fat it's
unique your pioneers of your own like
guerrilla marketing you own your own
label right so you own your own
publishing yeah like there's uh this
rabid fan base the way that you sell
merch is like Second To None you've got
the Gathering you just reeled off like
how uh like active and and and
productive okay so that says you've got
13 million now um that that that's a
good chunk of change and I'm not asking
you to confirm or deny if you have 13
million but what made me interested in
this is that uh talking to you and
talking to Shaggy like it's been
impossible for me to discern if you guys
are super humble and understating like
how financially successful you are or if
you're genuinely like out of your minds
and don't even know what you're doing so
basically blink twice if you have 13
million
on the I'm afraid to say nothing
um and by the way apologies if this
is a totally disrespectful oh no bro I
wouldn't even I just front if I didn't
want to you know what I'm saying yeah I
mean yeah you know we've been doing
things ourselves for so long that um
pretty much I mean this has been the way
it's been since we made our first dollar
all the money we make goes back into the
company you know what I mean and um
when we started making more and more
money you know it it pretty much stayed
like that right except for we would take
what we needed you get what I'm saying
like we were that we go to our manager
and be like hey can I get a car you'd be
like well what do you want you know and
it's like that you know then we're like
man how about a house you know okay but
we didn't get paid like that because we
were so from the Grassroots putting
everything back yeah so we didn't get
paid like that like like you like we
should have we were just kids starting
to ban even into our Platinum success we
were like that still yeah we never had
set up nobody came in our world and was
doing our money and setting up contracts
we just kept doing it like we like we
did it so um when we when our our
manager who we started everything went
finally left after like 15 years
um
our our new manager our childhood friend
Billy came in the guy's with us now you
know and um we finally started actually
making uh like a monthly paycheck you
know what I mean but anyway to tell you
to tell you the deal when I look at that
I think if I'm if I'm worth 13 million
it's when I'm dead you know what I mean
like if I die we might be worth 13
million you know what I'm saying like
like all the merch that might sell or
something like that you know what I'm
saying well that says like I don't have
13 [__] I don't even have a I mean I
of course I have a bank account I don't
have
a million in it [__] no I don't even got
500 000 in it or a hundred thousand I'll
keep it real in my personal account I
don't even have a hundred thousand
because everything is in Psychopathic
yeah still that's both me and Joey's
company and also like like the net worth
is not just the money in the bank
account it's everything that you own
Like Houses cars and it's that's what
I'm saying right but here's the thing
it's also absolute [__] like for
sure ever right yeah yeah no [__] no
that's what I'm saying look that just
makes it look like I'm chilling on 13
million like I got that chilling in the
bank or something you know first of all
we don't we're not me and Joey ain't
that type of guys where we don't sit and
live we don't live in mansions you know
what I mean we live in I live in houses
that my mom cleaned when I was a kid
that type of neighborhood because to me
that's rich you know what I'm saying
yeah right Shaggy uh created the
impression that on the the Gathering of
the Juggalos that like you know you guys
are making it such a big production that
you're actually not making anything no I
had to get it together my brother just
told me last week because we just had
the Gathering he was like there's five
thousand dollars left really let's look
together and that's what we cleared this
year you know after profit you know I
mean that's our profit do you know he
was heartbroken because he works his ass
off yeah you know what I'm sure I mean
dude like Justin what you spend on Faygo
yeah
dude I uh I'm just sitting here and I
just wanted to
articulate this that like I I feel like
I owe you an apology for putting you on
the financial blast that I did I'm not a
rich kid though right but I'm I'm beyond
I mean
I came from yeah man let me tell you
something I rented a Bentley
where are we at we're in a Hollywood
Hills yeah I Airbnb to my [__]
Hollywood Mansion yeah right a Bentley
for me and a [__]
um uh McLaren for my son Jay-Z oh really
yeah just for this trip to Florida I was
like man let's throw it up big I'm from
[__] food stamps and powdered milk so
I am rich that [__] might say I
make 13 million or I have 13 million and
like I said it might actually be worth
that if we sold all our [__] and
everything and our our uh Masters and
everything yeah that's what I'm saying
so I can't say but our finances are so
tied up in the [__] company that I
know I don't have I don't live like that
my house ain't no million dollar house
you know what I mean well where I live
you know should we pull up Steve's net
worth
I I think it says I'm worth 2.5 Oh I
thought I saw six at one point oh really
why when were you looking upstairs
they bumped me up to four to four wait a
[__] minutes there's no [__] way I
got more money than you son what are we
talking about here
I got 13 million and Stevo got four we
got 3x what he has yeah dude man that is
on crack that is so on crack man I'm
just I'm a chump dude
man yeah there's no way there's no
[__] man I'm living just outside of
Detroit Dodge Stevo was a household name
yeah what is that where do they get that
ah I mean what's bam at these days they
said 5 million
wow dude
[Laughter]
yeah the guy's a jackass ranked
I think Zach had like 1.5 on there yeah
really yeah it's it's just not accurate
stuff man but why would they think yeah
that's insane but we're cool right of
course Brothers
oh good now give me my word bro yeah I'm
not come on I'm the last one how many
millions have 3.5
that's probably accurate he does own a
lot of Real Estate
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude